[Music]
all right let's go out to the concrete
jungles where dreams are made of to New
York and talk to Monica what's up
Monica hi Dr bone thank you for speaking
with me of course thank you for calling
what's
up um well my question is I'm like in my
mid 50s maybe late 50s and uh that was
awesome I'm 42 and by 42 I mean like 61
that was awes um and I just you know my
life is sort of pathetic and I don't
really know what to do next like I don't
know how to fix it or what to do um how
hold on hold on you can't just drop that
challenge and leave old man that's from
K kid one all right so Define pathetic
for me give me a couple of data points
that suggest Monica my new friend is
pathetic I got a pen I'm writing these
down Do
It um you know I'm 56 years old I'm not
married I don't have kids I hold on hold
on neither of those things count so
continue that doesn't make you
pathetic that makes you single so go
ahead you know I just sort of have like
made I'm really nervous I'm sorry um no
don't be nervous you're my friend we're
just having
nachos I've made like a whole bunch of
like bad decisions like way back you
know I like I messed up my like 20s by
like just getting high and drinking um
and then got sober and then sort of like
hit out can I can can I just keep
interrupting you is that okay sure okay
I know it makes hard for our audience to
listen but I just want to stop you as
we're going okay if we were in coun I'd
let you spend all these out and we'd
pull each one of these apart but I just
want to stop you
here what in your
20s
um
what in your 20s doing drugs and
drinking was your body trying to protect
you from that you grew up zero through
19 um I mean I had some you know I mean
overall I had a great
childhood I call bu I call bull crap on
that um on a
stick you know I had like a bunch of
years where like an older family member
did like some really messed up stuff
with me sexually so I think I you know
there was that stuff that I was trying
to Monica deal with
Monica for 10
years your body was trying to protect
you in the only way it knew
how you didn't waste anything you
survived yeah if there was a shipwreck
in the middle of the
ocean and you got hit on the head as the
boat went down and you floated and
treaded
water and eventually somebody picked you
up or eventually the waves brought you
to
shore would anybody say wow you sure
wasted an opportunity to swim real
hard no they would say thank God you're
alive right now is there better ways to
handle childhood sexual
abuse on paper yes there
is did you
survive yeah yeah you did yeah you
did yeah I mean you know I'm definitely
one of those people who believe you know
getting high probably saved my life I
probably would have killed myself if I
didn't so I mean that's that's the
that's only somebody who truly
understands addiction can say that and
hear it and I'm with you okay high five
you thank you um so yeah so like you
know that was my 20s and
then I mean I never left I mean I'm in
AA I never left but I didn't stay sober
that whole time um but it's just been
like a series of like bad decisions give
me some more give me what was the bad
decision in your
30s um just like relapsing you know like
not staying sober and trying to deal
with my past and not really trusting
anyone to be able to tell anyone the
truth so like it just sort of wasted a
lot of years um
and I don't know like going to dead end
jobs when I could have done something
else but I was basically too afraid
because I just I just sort of got stuck
in like these jobs that I thought there
was a future and there wasn't a future
Monica somebody who was your
family the One Tribe on planet Earth
that's supposed to love you and keep you
safe
hurt you in one of the most powerful and
destructive ways a person can hurt
somebody
else and that never should
happen I'm I'm just sick and so sorry
that that
happened and I'm so sick and sad that
you didn't have an environment in your
home where it was okay to say
something yeah that it was not okay
that's not yeah and so don't come here
not telling the full truth my childhood
was great it wasn't it was
hell and what made it worse is that you
were burning alive inside your own skin
and you had to keep a smile on that face
and make sure the house was
okay yeah and so I want you to be real
real nice to 20 and 30 year old
Monica because everything this wasn't an
intellectual exercise for you your body
said no one can be
trusted yeah you got to figure this out
on your
own right yeah I mean it was yeah I mean
it wasn't until I mean you know I'm
still over a long time now um how
long uh in January it'll be 20
years so you know it's been a long time
now straight gangster Monica
thank you all right so you got sober at
36 tell me about your
40s um I just sort of you I mean I went
to therapy I did like you know EMDR like
did all that stuff and but I got badly
into debt you know like I just sort of
you know I gained a ton of weight
and um I guess I kind of like hid out in
AA because I didn't know know what else
to do you know and um
yeah I just you know like I stated a job
that I thought there was a future and
then that like imploded a few years ago
um and it just been like one bad
decision like you know like getting to
debt getting out of debt and now like
I'm back in debt you know like I I lost
like you know I finally lost the weight
like I lost um over Co like right right
after covid I lost like 75 pounds and
now I've gained 10 pounds back and it's
like you know like I'm just like I feel
like I just can't seem to I can't get it
together you know like I I can't date I
you know like I just here's here's the
fundamental here's the fundamental
thing you think Monica is
broken you don't like
Monica
yeah think about this if you had a car
that you were pretty sure wouldn't run
right
and that was pretty sure was really
ugly you would never drive it unless you
absolutely had to you would take a taxi
you'd call an Uber you take the bus you
take the you take the
train yeah you'd avoid that
car how in the world can somebody love
you Monaco when you won't love
you right how in the world can somebody
I don't know how to change that what I
don't know how to change that you've got
to let 20-year-old Monica
go she fought like hell for
you she had a really weird way of
punching and kicking but she kept
fighting and 30-year-old Monica for
about half that decade fought and kicked
and probably started crashing and
burning and 36-year-old Monica did the
hardest thing Monica's ever had to do
which is get rid of that crutch cuz the
thing that kept you alive in your 20s
was going to kill you in your
30s
mhm and then you Eed out trust with a
employer and they burned you and your
body was like told you quit trusting
right
yeah yeah and on the marathon of life
you walked your 40s you just said I'm
not gonna I'm gonna quit sprinting and
running and stopping and crashing I'm
going to walk cool here we are MH
nothing you have told me is
pathetic not one thing is pathetic do I
wish it had played out differently for
you starting with child abuse starting
with um a home where you were a window
ornament and a air freshener for your
family
yes I wish with all my guts it had been
different and it
wasn't and yeah do I wish that kind of
trauma hadn't sent you on a 30-year
journey of trying to figure out how to
stay alive I do with all my guts and
here we
are yeah I just like I don't know what
to do I don't know what I just don't
know what to do you know like my mom is
85 and like in the last six months it
sort of hit me like oh God like I could
easily have another 30 years of this oh
you got 30 years
easy you're too strong you're too wrong
and so the question before you is this I
mentioned this in a previous call and I
wrote a whole chapter on this in a
book The Path before
you has two
paths both of them
suck they do they're both G to be hard
you trying to White Knuckle sobriety
alone and work dead end jobs in a really
expensive place to live it's going to be
very
hard very very
hard you spending some time for giving
Monica and celebrating Monica for
keeping you
alive learning to trust again when every
single cell in your body is going to
tell you not to that's G to be
hard not losing weight because you don't
like Monica and you think Monica's gross
but losing weight and staying a good
Steward of your body because Monica's
freaking awesome and she deserves to
feel good when she wakes up it's going
to be
hard getting out of debt not because I'm
such a freaking pathetic bum and I keep
borrowing no not owing anybody any money
because For the first time in my life
nobody's gonna own
Monica I'm gon walk down the street with
my head held
high yeah see what I'm
saying yeah
yeah it seems I don't know it's yeah
here here's the here's the truth and
here's how I know I'm not just I'm not
not just spitting bull craap at you have
you heard the story of my
mom no my mom wasn't allowed to go to
college she grew up in a religious group
that wouldn't allow her to go to
college my dad always told her to go the
kid my brother and sister and I we
always cheered her on at the age of 42
she finally got a job as I mean she
finally went to her first Community
College Class
42 I was in high school I think my
sister was a freshman in college and I
had a little brother she took one class
next semester she took one more class
next semester she took one more
class at 57 she graduated with her
PhD wow this year I think she's 73 or 74
I'm not a great son she spent her last
summer at o for in London or outside of
London teaching
students in her
70s she would not get on a plane in her
40s wouldn't get on
it and so I not only is this like you're
worth more I'm not just throwing
Instagram quotes at you I've seen it in
my
house wow okay okay mhm the question I
have for you is are you willing to not
try to find love not try to find a job
are you willing to put the work in to
love
Monica yeah I just don't know I don't
know how people do that like I don't get
it I got you are you
in yeah all right here's I'm going to
give you a bunch of stuff to get you
started and then you're going going to
owe me a couple of homework assignments
is that a fair trade yeah sure all right
so gift number one I'm giving you own
your past change your future my number
one bestselling book on I'm G give it to
you for free it's about trauma I want
you to read it and it's the more
importantly than the descriptions of
trauma is the back end which is what do
I do
now what are the exercises what are the
things I need to do
okay a lot of therapy is a lot of
talking and talking is important but
also you have to go act you have to go
do something different and it's time for
you to do something different fair
enough yeah all right you're G to read
that book and then I'm going to give you
my most recent bestselling book building
a non-anxious life and it's a road map
to living a life where you can your body
can finally
go so then when that guy offers you a
job you can go dude I'm not working for
you I can see this now or when that guy
asked you for coffee you can go yeah my
body thinks he's safe I'm
in
Okay the third thing I'm going to send
you all of Financial Peace University
for
free all the videos all everything okay
okay all nine
lessons and I'm going to send you the
best app on planet Earth for budgeting
every dollar app for a year for
free and it automatically links to your
bank and when you spend something it
lets you know and it teaches you how to
budget and walks it all the way through
it okay okay the next thing I'm gonna
send you for free is I'm going to send
you um two sessions with a financial
coach here at Ramsey Solutions where I
work and they're going to talk through
your actual numbers
okay okay and help you get they're going
to walk alongside you and help you build
a budget and 50 6y old Monica is going
to go it's so stupid I don't have to
build a budget dude everybody needs help
it's all good M okay yeah the next thing
I'm going to give
you is my friend Ken Coleman's book for
paycheck to
purpose we're going to help you get a
job I'm also going to send you his get
clear assessment which is an assessment
which is like all right I'm 56 what the
heck do I want to do for the next 30
Years yeah okay uhhuh I got you all
those tools here's what you owe me thank
you all right I don't know it's probably
a $ thousand dollars and more worth of
stuff here's what here's what um you owe
me you owe me a promise that before the
weekend is over you're going to write a
letter to 24 year-old
Monica and that letter is going to start
with dear Monica thank you so much for
keeping me
alive and I want you to go down memory
lane
remember that one
time I cannot believe you did that what
were you
thinking I can't believe you got in that
car and you went to that place and you
made that deal and you end up in that
hospital you ended up with those
guys yeah and you were doing whatever
you had to do to keep me alive thank
you okay and then you're going to write
a letter to 30-year-old Monica the one
that decided I'm going to go get sober
and you're going to tell her thank you
for entering into the pit of Hell yet
again this time without a sword and
without a
shield because the Sword and the shield
for a long time was alcohol and drugs
and she went back in with nothing just
AA and then I want you to write 56y old
Monica a
letter and that letter is going to be
you talking to yourself and it's going
to start dear Monica I love you
so glad you're still
here here's who we're going to become
are you ever going to be a millionaire
probably
not are you ever gonna own a 5,000
square foot house probably
not so let's don't be S let's don't like
you know what I'm saying like let's
don't project this like I'm gonna
manifest what no let's don't do that if
you become a millionaire I'll cheer you
on dude I'll be so
happy
right here's what I want for you I want
you to look up and be
80 and have a small condo that you own
it's yours all by yourself nobody owns
it or maybe even a small
house and I want you to have a little
bit of retirement in Social Security I I
want you to have a car that is a good
running car that you own
completely don't you have a small
retirement you see what I'm saying you
to begin to paint that picture are you
going to have a Rolls-Royce out there no
are you going to have a paid for Camry
or Corolla
yes if you have a paid for Corolla at
the age of 62 I promise that car is
still going before long after you are
right because those cars never stop
running right but here's what we're
grieving the picture we're grieving the
I thought it was G it's not and here's
what it is going to look
like and at 62 to you might be a
teacher you might be a businesswoman you
might be a small business owner I don't
know what you're going to
be but you're going to have your head
held high you're going to be
proud you're going to be knocking these
things out you're gonna have some
friends that come over to your
house some weird whacka dooodle Doo
friends that come over to Monica's house
and hang
out
because you love
them because
you love
you pry Monica this is the your
Independence Day Monica's free starting
today you've been sober for 20 years
game
on I I just put all the chips in all of
them I call Monica your
move